bonjour et bienvenue dans europe hebdo
au parlement européen
ici à bruxelles et cette semaine nous
irons en espagne à marina del à cette
petite ville andalouse défilé politique
d'austérité de madrid son maire à
collectiviser les moyens de production
mais l'actualité de cette semaine c'est
bien sûr le prix nobel de la paix
accordé à l'union européenne
c'est une bonne nouvelle pour l'europe
mais ne s'agit-il pas d'une erreur
c'est la question posée par nora hamadi
d'un nourrisson nobel comme états unis
l'europe prix nobel de la paix qui l'eût
cru personne à vrai dire
parce qu'aujourd'hui l'europe pour ces
peuples c'est plutôt le prix nobel de
l'austérité dans les capitales
européennes les manifestations se
suivent et se ressemblent plan
d'austérité contre plan de rigueur
triple à contre pigs pays du nord contre
état du club med cigale contre fourni et
vous dit
une somme supra shoes d'afficheurs
riches est fort de good as vu leurs
peines allant de huit fois debout
vaudois oui acheté la machine au pétrole
propane
pis des mots-clés human rights in last
of the world
mais tout le monde est content c'est le
principal à l'heure où l'union sans plus
dans la crise et peinent à s'extraire de
son inertie portique cette distinction
fleurs dont la boutade ne faudrait-il
pas mieux valu couronner les pères
fondateurs
alors ce prix nobel une erreur
alors nous sommes sur ce plateau avec
sylvie goulard bonjour vous êtes députée
européenne vous êtes française vous
appartenait au groupe des démocrates et
des libéraux ici au parlement européen
ce prix nobel de la paix est ce que
c'est une erreur
je comprends qu'on soit surpris par le à
part le choix en ce moment mais je pense
que c'est aussi une invitation à
réfléchir dans le temps et dans l'espace
dans le temps parce que je pense que les
jurés du nobel ont voulu honorer toute
la construction communautaire ses
soixante années de paix la période la
plus longue qu'on n'ait jamais connu sur
ce continent
donc je crois qu'il faut surtout éviter
de prendre les hommages pour nous c'est
plutôt des hommages pour ceux qui ont
commencé à un moment où c'était
difficile et vous dire s'ils avaient
suivi les sondages à l'époque
probablement on n'aurait pas fait la
réconciliation franco-allemande et la
paix et puis c'est aussi un hommage dans
l'espace ça vient d'eux d'un pays qui
est extérieur à l'union européenne
je crois que quand on regarde l'état du
monde même les tensions qui existent en
asie en ce moment pour des conflits
territoriaux
je pense que les européens peuvent
réfléchir un petit peu à ce que l'europe
leur a apporté après c'est pas une
raison pour nier qu'il ya des problèmes
graves
est-ce que ça via pas malgré tout un peu
à contretemps moi j'ai été assez surpris
des réactions négatives des citoyens
européens qui disait effectivement le
prix nobel de l'austérité on viens de
l'entendre
l'europe a peut-être le prix nobel de la
paix mais là pas le prix nobel de
l'économie du social
est ce que finalement il n'aurait pas
fallu que ça devienne plus tôt peut-être
que d'ici peu moins qu'il ait donné ce
qui me frappe quand même c'est que en ce
moment il ya un espèce de contresens qui
est en train d'être propagées
surtout que les on est dans tous les
tous les blogs etc c'est que ça serait
l'europe qui est la cause des problèmes
économiques elle a sa part de
responsabilité mais il faut bien appeler
aux téléspectateurs que les politiques
économiques étaient du ressort des états
membres et que justement on n'a pas fait
les politiques économiques de la zone
euro
ensemble et donc il faut aussi qu'ils
s'en prennent à ceux qui les ont dirigés
dans chacun des pays et l'une des
difficultés qu'on a en ce moment c'est
de préserver un cadre que chacun était
censé préserver pour ce qui le concerne
et que certains ont complètement
bousillé donc encore une fois il s'agit
pas du tout de disculper l'europe pour
ce qu'elle aurait fait de faux mais
faire aussi remarquer que les budgets en
déficit l'absence d'investissements dans
l'avenir les systèmes éducatifs handicap
il au talent c'est pas non plus toujours
la faute à bruxelles
alors on a appris ce nobel est de
l'histoire de ce nobel de la paix il ya
quelques jours maintenant est-ce qu ici
au parlement européen
il ya une fierté par rapport à
l'attribution de ce prix c'est moi c'est
toujours important de savoir se réjouir
y compris dans les moments de difficulté
encore une fois je dis bien il s'agit
pas de de fer taratata et d'ignorer les
difficultés des personnes en europe et
de beaucoup de gens qui ont de qui
affronte les conditions de vie
difficiles mais je pense à me faire les
américains disent tout le temps by
positive soyez positif c'est un des
leitmotiv des américains sert que fait
toujours aussi de voir que le côté
négatif on peut de temps en temps se
dire tiens pourquoi est-ce que des
étrangers à l'union européenne considère
que ce projet vaut la peine est ce que
nous le jugeons bien ça fait réfléchir
là une autre information de la semaine
on a appris la démission d'un
commissaire européen du commissaire john
dalli qui le guettait le commissaire à
la santé et aux consommateurs sur des
soupçons de fraude
est-ce que ça dure en tout cas de trafic
d'influencé
est-ce que la corruption est quelque
chose qui est selon vous à présent au
niveau européen
d'abord je trouve que lorsqu'il ya un
problème que quelqu'un démissionne c'est
le signe que le système fonctionne
plutôt bien
encore une fois je n'ai pas
personnellement des élus
en sur ce qu'a fait ou n'a pas fait
monsieur dany je trouve qu'il faut
toujours être très très prudent avant
d'accuser il ya un service qui s'appelle
l'office de lutte antifraude qui semble
avoir fait un rapport effectivement qui
aboutit à des conclusions qui appelle
des mesures et je les approuve si elles
sont exactes il ya de la corruption mais
si vous regardez par exemple ce qui se
passe en ce moment dans un pays comme
l'italie si vous vous souvenez de ce qui
s'est passé au royaume uni au parlement
je pense que les êtres humains sont
toujours soumis à des tentations et que
ce qui est important c'est que les
systèmes politiques arrêtent les dérives
sans avoir l'illusion de penser qui en
aura pas il y en a au niveau européen
sans doute
j'ai l'impression quand même qu'on
accable parfois l'europe sans regarder
ce qui se passe ailleurs au niveau local
ou au niveau national
vous diriez que simple un peu la même
chose là c'est plutôt il faut plutôt
aller voir ce qui se passe dans les
états que ce qui se passe au niveau de
bruxelles
il faut assumer les responsabilités pour
ce qui a pu y avoir de négatif
il faut jamais le cacher mais il faut
pas non plus isolés ces questions-là de
ce qui se passe dans certains états
membres où vous avez des problèmes
extrêmement grave dans les rentrées
fiscales dans le muselage de l'argent
public par des collectivités locales ou
voir des cas de corruption avérés dans
des parlements
encore une fois je crois que ce sont des
phénomènes qu'il faut combattre parce
que la corruption c'est une un cancer
pour la société ça veut dire que
l'argent public est mal utilisé que les
décisions sont mal prises mais encore
une fois pour l'instant c'est un
commissaires sur 27
il faut qu'on attend de voir les
résultats de l' enquête alors sylvie
goulard il ya quelques jours ici même au
parlement européen vous avez fait j'ai
envie de dire beaucoup parlé de vaud va
regarder une petite intervention que
vous avez fait publiquement et ensuite
on est nouveau ensemble regarder
vous me direz à mario draghi
non je m'adresse à mario draghi pas le
président mais l'homme de bon sens
comment voyez-vous les sept prochaines
années
et c'est en tant que président d'une
institution qui pousse tout le monde en
europe à se moderniser à mettre en
oeuvre des réformes structurelles pour
pousser plus de femmes au travail et qui
reste une institution du passé qui
n'emploie que des hommes on lit mais
dynamique discrimination et non il n'y a
pas de discrimination à la bce mais bien
sûr toutes les institutions
bon alors pour que le téléspectateur
comprennent bien en fait vous parliez de
la parité ou de l'absence de parité
homme femme à la banque centrale
européenne il ya vingt-trois personnes
qui dirigent cette cette banque et ce
sont 23 hommes est ce que vous avez été
satisfait par la réponse du président de
la bce
non j'ai pas été satisfaites par sa
réponse puisqu'il a dit qu'il ya pas
discrimination moi je trouve quand même
que quand on a des règles de droit qui
disent que a priori les hommes et les
femmes sont égaux et qu'à la fin on se
retrouve avec 23 sur 23 c qui est quand
même un problème quelque part cela dit
je ne voulais pas accabler mario draghi
ce sont les ministres des finances qui
sont en train de prendre une décision à
mon sens non seulement grave mais un peu
bête pour être franchement faut pour
dire les choses comme elles sont qui est
de désigner un sixième homme au sein du
directoire ce que les 23 c'est six
membres du directoire plus les 17
gouverneurs des banques centrales
nationales les 17 gouverneurs des
banques centrales nationales on peut se
demander pourquoi ya pas une femme et sa
relève des états mais dans l'organe qui
est vraiment supranationale européen on
pourrait quand même au moins faire un
effort et quand vous parlez de parité
moi j'ai envie de dire on ne fait même
pas la charité parce que même pas un sur
six c'est lamentable
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est un
combat qui est perdu d'avancé puisque
ici par exemple le président du
parlement européen martin schulz a
laissé entendre que cet effet que ce
sera ce luxembourgeois qui va être nommé
au directoire et c'est un homme écoutez
moi je n'ai rien contre ce monsieur mais
je crois que c'est une banale
qui valait la peine d'être mené d'abord
j'espère qu'on va la gagner a priori on
en a fait l'audi si on a accepté de
faire l'audition la semaine prochaine
parce que jusqu'à nouvel ordre des
groupes politiques se sont mis d'accord
pour rendre un vote négatif
donc le conseil devra voter contre
l'avis du le choisir ce monsieur contre
l'avis du parlement
et puis moi je crois que vis-à-vis des
électeurs qui nous ont envoyés ici
vis-à-vis des femmes mais aussi de
nombreux hommes qui me contactent qui
nous soutiennent dans ce combat c'est un
combat juste et ça montre écouté que le
président du parlement le président du
conseil européen
tous les ministres de l'économie ne vois
pas le problème
moi j'ai le sentiment que la modernité
est avec nous et c'est eux qui sont
aveugles et ringard mais c'est à eux de
décider
j'aimerais comprendre le parlement va
voter contre alors que le président du
parlement dit que ça va être accepté
mais le président du parlement à son
interprétation de ce que nous avons fait
en commission économique et monétaire
il a probablement envie ça peut se
concevoir d'ailleurs de favoriser des
compromis usa et l'europe et beaucoup
fondée sur des compromis
il ya des tas de cas dans lesquels moi
je soutiens le compromis simplement là
il n'y a pas de compromis possible à la
fin où on aura un homme
il n'y a pas d'autres nominations
pendant sept ans c'est pour ça que j'ai
dit à mario draghi est ce que vous voyez
pendant sept ans à la tête de cette
bande de mecs ou est-ce que 2,7 à la
tête de cette bande de mecs parce que
s'il faut bien appeler les choses par
leur nom tout le monde est poli tout le
monde me dit que la parité c'est un
sujet d'une importance considérable et
ne fait rien moi je préférerais que ce
parlement prenne ses responsabilités
votre nom et le conseil décidera un
compromis entre un homme et une femme je
sais pas quoi ça ressemblerait alors on
va maintenant faire comme chaque semaine
notre zapping des télévisions
européennes on s'arrête sur ce que les
médias étrangers ont décidé de traiter
et cette semaine c'était beaucoup sur
les indépendantisme en europe
regardez c'est un zapping signé aurélie
la face
c'est décidé l'ecosse aura son
référendum avant la fin 2014
les écossais ont donc deux ans pour
décider de leur sort
dans la plupart des sondages environ un
tiers des votants se prononce pour
l'indépendance ce qui laisse donc une
large part de la population indécise
mais déjà l'idée relance les velléités
indépendantistes catalanes
le parlement régional souhaite une
consultation populaire dans les rues de
barcelone
un espoir est en train de renaître
l'exemple écossais a démontré qu'un
accord était possible
le gouvernement catalan menace d'
internationaliser le conflit si madrid
refuse le dialogue la population
catalane continuent d'être divisée en
deux la majorité des catalans et pour
l'indépendance
il veut que le sujet soit soumis au vote
et marché à la schl
en belgique ce sont les flamands qui
envoie un signal fort
le leader indépendantiste bart de wever
triomphe un an vers des élections
locales à l'impact national et aux
flamands a donné un signal très clair
pas seulement à la mer mais aussi à la
rue de la loi qui ne supporte pas un
gouvernement qui n'est pas supportée par
une majorité en flandre qui ne fait qu
imposer les gens c'est inacceptable cela
doit arrêter la première étape de la
conquête de la flandre qui aura des
conséquences sur l'ensemble du pays ce
que j'espère oui
alors entre la flandre l'ecosse et la
catalogne est ce qu'il ya selon vous des
points communs oui je crois qu'on
assiste à des phénomènes qui montre sans
amalgamer sont de l'ordre du repli sur
l'échelon régional parce qu'on s'y sent
plus à l'aise avec parfois aussi un
élément et c'est ça qui est très
inquiétant de refus de la solidarité
c'est la raison pour laquelle
personnellement je peux comprendre ces
attitudes mais je ne crois pas qu'il
faille encourager ces phénomènes la
dislocation des états européens
indépendamment de la construction
européenne à mon avis n'est pas une
bonne chose pour l'europe pour sa force
dans le monde et n'est surtout pas une
bonne chose pour le partage du fardeau
il ya des régions plus riches que
d'autres c'est vrai qu'elle paye parfois
plus que d'autres mais il faut aussi se
poser la question de savoir ce qu'est
une solidarité si les riches ne payent
pas je mets les pieds dans le plat qu'on
me dit au début je suis assez stupéfait
aussi par le silence assourdissant
justement niveau européen face à ce que
ces régionalisme est également ses dires
et csc nationalisme quand on voit pas ce
qui se passe avec aube dorée en grèce à
bruxelles personne ne dénonce ça comment
c'est possible
non c'est dénoncer je me souviens d'un
débat récent au parlement européen où on
a beaucoup interpellé monsieur barroso
là dessus en fin de sa vie mais lui non
mais lui même l'a dit dans ses discours
et donc je crois que monsieur van rompuy
on est préoccupé la vraie question c'est
que ce sont des mouvements profonds
qu'un certain nombre de partis
politiques modérés qui autrefois ne
jouez pas avec ces idées là jouent avec
le feu que nous avons des phénomènes de
repli que nous avons des discours
identitaire nous en avons eu en france
récemment à des moments où nos sociétés
sont de plus en plus mêlée où la
compétition mondiale est de plus en plus
redoutable
je crois qu'il faut inviter les gens à
faire la part des instincts des
instincts et de la raison c'est pas dans
notre intérêt
on va parler du nobel de la paix
au début de cette interview est ce que
malgré tout vous pensez pas que la
parole européenne devrait être plus
forte la dessus oui résolument oui il
faut combattre le nationalisme le
nationalisme françois mitterrand disait
le nationalisme c'est la guerre
on croit toujours que le premier stade
est innocent on croit toujours qu'on
peut flatter les identités monter les
gens contre les autres et après il ya
une deuxième étape qu'on ne soupçonnait
même pas quand on s'est lancé dans la
première qui est celle de la dégradation
et peut-être même du conflit
donc je suis entièrement d'accord avec
vous nous n'avons pas à avoir honte de
ce qui a été fait ici ça a permis
peut-être d'ailleurs que certains de
ceux qui critiquent aujourd'hui serait
mort s'il y avait eu des conflits et ils
n'ont même pas la décence de dire merci
schumann merci maman merci en tout cas
sylvie goulard d'avoir accepté notre
invitation va continuer bien sûr à
parler de l'europe avec kathia gilder et
son invité nous allons partir en espagne
nous allons parler de la crise espagnole
et nous allons aller dans une petite
ville d'andalousie dans lequel le maire
a développé un modèle économique et
social unique
là bas il n'y a pas de chômage regardez
c'est un reportage signé sandra
cerqueira
tout l'été ils ont marché sur les routes
d'andalousie pour dire non à la crise
derrière celui que les espagnols
surnomme robin des bois
il a pris la tête d'un mouvement de
résistance populaire
bien décidé à convaincre les maires de
ne pas obéir à la politique d'austérité
les coupes budgétaires se font sur le
dos des travailleurs
ce gouvernement de droite a fait tout le
contraire de ce qu'il a promis
c'est pourquoi il est illégitime
il faut le chasser au plus vite une
marche et des opérations coup de poing
dans les supermarchés pour aider les
pauvres touchés par la crise les ti-cats
on m'a bien sûr beaucoup critiqué pour
tout ça mais ça n'est pas du vol c'est
un acte d'insoumission sans violence
pour attirer l'attention et montrer
qu'il faut voir de l'autre côté de la
crise ceux qui n'ont plus rien même plus
de quoi manger il faut une rébellion
citoyenne pour mettre en place un autre
modèle économique et politique
sinon ça va être terrible c'est le
militant de la gauche anticapitaliste
qui parle
il y à 30 ans juan manuel gordillo
décide de lancer dans sa ville une
expérience des plus originales petite
commune andalouse située à une heure de
céline des noms de rues évocateur et des
fresques au slogan de révolte pas de
police municipale
une sorte d'enclavé communiste en plein
coeur de l'europe fondée sur une
économie à 90% public alors que
l'andalousie et la région espagnole la
plus touchée par le chômage avec un taux
de 34 % à marinaleda tout le monde
travaille
une bonne partie des habitants est
employé par la coopérative de la ville
créée par les ouvriers agricoles eux
mêmes après des années de lutte
en 1992 ils obtiennent gain de cause et
exproprient 1200 hectares de terre la
terre doit être à ceux qui la
travaillent dans le pays ça va mal et
nous on a la chance de ne pas connaître
le chômage
notre exemple montre qu'on est une
solution viable face aux marchés quel
que soit leur poste à responsabilité ou
nous tous reçoivent la même chose
47 euros par jour et effectue une
rotation afin d'assurer un revenu à tous
l'objectif de la coopérative
ce n'est pas de s'enrichir c'est de
donner du travail et ça on ne le voit
pratiquement nulle part les autres ils
veulent gagner toujours plus d'argent
mécanisée pour qu'il y ait le moins de
main d'oeuvre est ici ce n'est pas sale
but mais avec la crise ils sont de plus
en plus nombreux à venir postuler pour
travailler dans les champs
difficile de donner du travail à tout le
monde parmi les chômeurs qui arrivent
beaucoup était dans le bâtiment au
moment où l'espagne est en proie au boom
de l'immobilier marinaleda décide
d'aller à contre-courant en favorisant
l'autoconstruction il est possible d'y
louer une maison de 90 m 15
pour 15 euros par mois il faut
absolument que chacun aide à la
construction de son logement et à celui
de ses voisins on est 18 dans la rue on
s'entraide et si on ne peut pas le faire
on fait appel à quelqu'un d'autre de la
famille c'est la commune qui propose les
terrains et fournit le matériel
nécessaire à la construction des
logements on est subventionnée on
rembourse en payant un peu chaque mois
ne sera propriétaire que dans 60 ou 70
ans
c'est une façon d'éviter la vente et
donc la spéculation
de même il est impossible de nous
hypothéquons car on ne fait pas appel
aux banques pour un crédit
lusine de la coopérative où les récoltes
se mise en conserve appartient aussi à
ceux qui travaillent les moyens sont
collectiviser et les prises de décisions
aussi les habitants participent à des
assemblées publiques et décident
ensemble de ce à quoi est destiné le
budget de la ville
de cette façon on est sûr que les
décisions sont bonnes pour tout le monde
ça n'a pas l'air comme ça mais on doit
lutter parfois durement pour imposer ce
système municipal
beaucoup de politiques pourrait suivre
notre exemple mais ça ne les intéresse
pas que tu nous ne puissent vivre
dignement menace procès à droite comme à
gauche on critique un système qui sans
les aides publiques de la communauté
autonome d'andalousie ne serait pas
viable
d'autres dénoncent le populisme d'un
homme réélu régulièrement depuis 30 ans
qui chaque samedi et en direct pendant
une heure sur la télé locale de la ville
située juste à côté de la mairie
voilà pour ce reportage réalisé par
sandra cerqueira à marinaleda et pour en
parler nous accueillons monsieur miguel
angel martinez bonjour bonjour merci
d'être avec nous est député européen
espagnol socialiste et démocrate
on vient de voir ensemble à quoi pouvait
ressembler un îlot rouge si je puis dire
au coeur de l'europe
est ce que pour vous c'est totalement
utopique ou au contraire est-ce que ça
peut être une solution aussi non
seulement non seulement ce n'est pas
utopique mais mais c'est celui ci a rien
de nouveau ladder vous savez il ya ya
soixante dix en espagne
daisy lowe comme ça il y en a eu le
communisme libertaire
ll e
le passé la tradition anarchiste qui
fait qu'en espagne il ya eu
dans le dans ce qu'on a appelé l'anarcho
syndicalisme c'est des expériences qui
ont eu lieu un peu partout
elle sait d'expérience qui était
peut-être plus plus imaginable dans le
contexte agricole fondamentalement
agricole du du début du xxème siècle en
espagne je pense que à l'heure actuelle
c'est une
c'est une moi je pense que c'est une
c'est un cas qui qui qui qui est
nécessairement touchant parce que c'est
une réaction qui n'est pas seulement la
réaction d'un homme de dieu qui est
quand même la réaction d'une d'une
commune qui n'est pas un village qui est
unique et au niveau européen on dirait
quand même une petite ville c'est sympa
c'est pas du tout le travail et habitant
tout près et à peu près trente mille
habitants donc c'est très vite donc
c'est une ville avec tous les problèmes
la ville je pense que c'est une c'est
une initiative je touche en deux jours à
la limite et c'est une initiative qui se
situe absolument en dehors de tout
contexte qui qui qui qui pourrait qui
pourrait d'ailleurs amené à une très
grande eau sur station un moment où est
ce qu'on peut imaginer d'appliquer ce
genre d'expérience à une échelle plus
large
on peut tout on peut tout imaginer
madame l'imagination parfois il fait
défaut et on peut imaginer
mais ce que je vous dis on monte on
montre la confiance et il ya des
milliers et des milliers de coopératives
en espagne qui fonctionne d'ailleurs où
les gens où les gens vont travailler
dans ma province n'est pas très loin
d'eux
l'andalousie je viens de la mancha qui
avec des structures sociologique c'est
similaire avec la partie de la culture
de l'histoire espagnole même façon dans
ma vie dans ma région d'émilie et des
centaines de coopératives où les gens
sont en train de travailler des gens
trouvent du travail où l'on trouve du
travail pendant des périodes et bien
aidé pendant les périodes relativement
limité donc c'est moi je pense que c'est
une c'est une et c'est une initiative
touchante c'est une initiative
intéressante certainement et je ne crois
pas que l'on puisse imaginer un
phénomène ou les deux en cascade qu'il
fallait que tout le pays et que toute
l'europe deviendrait un mécanisme de ça
ça me fait penser moi au mode setting
absolument dépassées par la réalité
chinoise au jour il ya eu beaucoup de
portraits sur ce robin des bois
espagnols comme on avait pu l'appeler
comment est il perçu en espagne ce qu'il
est perçu comme un sauveur ou au
contraire contre comme un dangereux
utopiste non non non non non non mais
franchement je pense qu'il est je pense
qu'il il y à il y a quand même chez le
personnage aussi ne le cachons pas il ya
des gens qui ont parlé vraiment ça me
sais que c'est quand même c'est
quelqu'un aussi qui vit beaucoup du
médiatique comprenait la vente pure
consiste à une émission à la télévision
locale chaque jour ou presque j'ai dit
ça donc il ya de populisme lui disons
mais je vous dise
de toute façon dans le local ça se passe
dans base au clos c'est pas ça c'est à
dire ce qui est important pour lui c'est
qu'on en a parlé c'est qu'on a parlé un
peu partout à l'espagne même même à
l'extérieur je vois bien et que l'on a
parlé parce que ce qu'il a ce qu'il a
vraiment fait c'est défier la loi
c'est-à-dire ce métro rome
c'est aussi ça fait partie aussi la 2de
de la confusion générale qui est en
train de s'installer en espagne alors
justement nickel angel martinez par
vider les candidats au travail à
m'arrêter là de là il ya aussi beaucoup
de l'ancien ouvrier du bâtiment secteur
qui est quand même le point noir en
espagne est ce que est ce qu'on a réglé
ce problème immobilier qui est quand
même le talon d'achille de votre pays
qui goûte et je pense que notre notre
faute et dans une certaine mesure notre
chèque ça a été de savoir que ce
processus de bâtiments bâtiment bâtiment
était vouée à l'échec ça veut dire que
c'était aussi de l'immobilier
spéculatifs c'est ça le problème
aujourd'hui brice taton jouera
aujourd'hui d'abord aujourd'hui je ne
veux pas dire hélas mais aujourd'hui il
n'y a pas deux il n'y a pas de mathilde
un bâtiment qui pousse ni spéculatifs y
non spéculatifs ayant le problème
aujourd'hui il ya des centaines de
milliers de logements vides alors que
personne ne veut acheter ou ne peut
acheter et non seulement cela il ya des
il ya des dizaines de milliers de
logements qui ont été vendus à des gens
dans des conditions alors que les
banques que savait qu'il n'allait pas
pouvoir payer ou que normalement à un
moment où l'autre il pourrait pas prier
et on est en train de de leur enlever
ces bâtiments ces logements pour payer
et une fois qu'ils ont payé et alors ils
payent moins que ce que soi-disant la
banque donne justement puisqu'on parle
des banques est ce que la situation de
ce qu'est ce que la situation de
l'espagne notamment de ses banques
inquiète l'europe et on parle d'un
éventuel nouveau plan pour aider les
banques est ce que ça c'est
compréhensible alors même qu' à 25% de
la jeunesse espagnole aux chômage est ce
que ça vous choque qu'on aide les
banques
moi je je je pense que
l'aide aux banques devraient être
beaucoup plus conditionnée qu'elle ne
l'est c'est à dire qu'elles qu'elles
devraient être absolument conditionnée à
un certain contrôle est jeune je ne
comprends pas comment on peut aider des
banques qui continuent à payer des
sommes très importantes
j'avoue que je dois je croise en volume
ma naïveté parce que je ne je n'avais
jamais pu penser croire aux sommes qu'on
est en train d'apprendre maintenant que
toucher des membres le conseil
d'administration d'emakina ministre est
rien et pitié et fillon qui ont amené
des des sociétés à la ruine
ils ont continué à toucher donc donc
inutile qu'il fasse qu'il fasse soutenir
les banques
je veux bien qu'ils soient conditionnés
ce soutien de façon extrêmement sévère
mais je pense qu'il est indispensable
aussi et que le fait que l'on puisse
soutenir les banques
sans un contrôle sévère est connue la
population amène l'indignation de
nombreux citoyens comme c'est le cas
actuellement merci beaucoup d'avoir été
l'invitée d'europe hebdo on se retrouve
la semaine prochaine à strasbourg avec
nora hamadi très bonne ces deux
programmes sur les chaînes
parlementaires